Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my breakdown of all big
Superman flash announcements this
morning there's a bunch of Justice
League stuff going on with the CW and DC
TV series they announced all the details
for next year's big crossover episodes a
lot of Superman Batman stuff happening
also a lot of big DC movie stuff
happening that I'll explain during the
video too so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know which
new series you're most hyped about so
we'll just go down the list here
starting with number 5 The CW just
announced that the next season for all
the shows all the DC TV shows won't
start until January 2021 because of the
virus delays they won't be able to start
filming till way later this year so none
of the new shows will be able to get
their episodes out in time to get them
out before the end of the year so
they're just delaying everything to
midseason
hey yeah
you gonna clean that or what?
any day now
Come on Cinderella, scrub like you mean it.
This is what the full schedule looks
like when everything comes back in
January you notice there's a couple of
shows missing from here I'll explain
that later in the video too the most
important part here though is that the
new Superman TV show as predicted will
air back-to-back with the flash season 7
episodes on Tuesday nights they haven't
confirmed how many episodes they're
going to do for all the shows but since
none of them are premiering till
midseason that means they're probably
only going to do half season like 13 14
episodes tops for all the shows yes it
sucks to have to wait longer to get new
episodes but the good thing about doing
fewer episodes that will be less filler
what they've done to replace all that
missing programming in episodes later
this fall is they've actually bought the
rights to syndicate the swampthing TV
series from the DC streaming service a
lot of people saw that and mistook that
for the news that CW was renewing
swampthing for more seasons what they're
doing is is they just bought the
existing episodes and they're going to
rebroadcast them later this year the
star girl TV show is actually replacing
the flash next week so all the star
girls stuff from DC streaming service
will actually be airing this spring
that's basically a Justice Society TV
show
if you remember Jeff John's early
two-thousands run on just society
they're kind of doing a version of that
with updated versions of the characters
so for next big DC TV crossover details
it's going to be way different they
announced that it would mostly be a
two-hour Superman Batman type of story
like world's finest with the Batwoman TV
show they haven't revealed what the
official title is going to be the same
way that they announced crisis on
Infinite Earths a full year in advance
of the crisis episodes but the story
they'll be adapting will be from the
Superman Batman crossovers in the comics
this is the main reason why they're only
doing a to our smaller crossover is
because of the shortened seasons of all
the shows and just because the other
shows like the flash aren't named as
part of the crossover episodes doesn't
mean that the flash or other characters
won't be involved at all they just won't
be main characters during the crossover
the flash has enough epic material to
adapt for season 7 that it doesn't
really need a big crossover with the
other shows they have the real version
of God speed that they just teased as a
new villain they have the Red Death Dark
multiverse upgraded version of reverse
flash to introduced they have a new
version of Nora to debut and then all
the leftover storylines from the
canceled season six episodes to wrap up
I've already done a big video on the
flash season 7 teaser so I'll post a
link to that at the end of this video
but because the shows all won't start
till January next year the crossover
episodes won't actually happen until
next March or April right in the middle
of the seasons number three the Superman
TV show is still casting most of its
major characters but they've got free
run of any big Superman comic book
characters for whatever reason whatever
bargain they pulled maybe because Henry
Cavill doesn't have a Superman movie
coming out next year they can do pretty
much anything they want with Superman
characters they've already got their
version of lex luthor on earth prime but
one of the main antagonists early on for
the Superman series is going to be Lois
Lane's father general Lane played by
this actor here who you probably
recognize from a bunch of other series
he's not going to be the main villain at
first they have a mystery villain in
season 1 my early guesses is it'll be a
spin on some of the rebirth comics like
a Kryptonian villain maybe like Bendis
izj or el twist from the rebirth comics
or maybe a different version of Zod some
different type of spin on a Kryptonian
villain Zod is just kind of the default
introductory Superman villain usually
you see all the movies
the TV shows do him and Lex Luthor first
and they've kind of already done Lex
Luthor to death literally they actually
killed him and then brought him back to
life during crisis on Infinite Earths if
you missed the big Superman teaser at
the end of crisis on Infinite Earths one
of the big retcons they just made with
the rebirth version of Earth Prime is
that now Superman and Lois have two sons
instead of just the one John Kent's son
and instead of it being little babies
like you saw John Kent during crisis
when the Superman TV show picks up
they're both going to be teenage boys I
don't know how they're planning on
explaining the rapid age up in the two
different versions of Superboy but
they'll address it in that first episode
the way they describe developing the
powers of the two different versions of
Superboy made it sound like a spin on
Smallville and the way they developed
Clark Kent Superman's powers through the
first season the first couple of seasons
he slowly started to unlock to figure
out his new abilities I'm assuming it's
going to be something similar with the two
boys one of them is going to be a little
bit older I believe and will have more
powers than the younger one shifting
into the movies for those of you
wondering what's going on with Henry
cavils version of Superman there was a
rumor recently that Warner Brothers had
pivoted away from their idea to do a
Supergirl movie in favor of just going
back to straight-up Man of Steel Henry
Cavill Superman movies now there's no
date no director no storyline attached
to any of that stuff I mentioned it in a
video last week but right now it just
sounds like they're doubling back down
on Superman in some form they're already
a couple other movies that have tried to
use them like the Shazam movie recently
so you probably see Superman pop up in
cameos and other DC movies before you
see him in a straight-up Man of Steel
sequel for now Henry Cavill is still
Superman he still wants to be Superman
he's been pretty open about that even
though he's doing The Witcher Netflix TV
series the schedule around that will
allow him to do Superman movies it's not
that demanding but if we get any more
Henry Cavill Superman news of course
I'll do a video about that but number
two for those of you asking about the
Diggle Green Lantern in the arrow finale
teaser
yes Diggle got his Green Lantern ring
while he and Lyla were packing up to
move to Metropolis where the Superman
series is taking place I think a lot of
us are on the same page and we assumed
they're telling us they're going to do
Green Lantern Diggle cameos in
servers on the Superman series but Green
Lantern diggle isn't supposed to be a
main character on that show so I don't
know how many episodes he's going to get
maybe just one or two the producers said
that Warner Brothers gave them a laundry
list of rules and conditions that would
allow them to do Green Lantern stuff in
the arrowverse mostly because of the
upcoming Green Lantern HBO series from
Geoff Johns that's not connected to the
arrowverse right now it'll be different
versions of Hal Jordan Jon Stewart and
Sinestro during the big crisis on
Infinite Earths post-credit scene they
tease that all that Green Lantern HBO
stuff will be taking place in a
different universe of the multiverse so
crossover with the air over stuff isn't
impossible but it probably won't happen
for a long time in as far as the Batman
movie goes they're going to start filming
that again later this year as well -
it's still being released during 2021
they just had to bump the date a little
bit so it's still coming out but now
it's coming out in October the writer of
the movie was actually tweeting jokes
about how that was so much more
appropriate for the movie a Halloween
release because the joke is the movie is
based on the long Halloween comic book
storyline so which is funny how it winds
up working out that way
even though it does suck that it got
delayed the number one WTF I know a lot
of you saw this 2021 schedule and notice
that Supergirl legends are nowhere to be
found
that's not because they've been canceled
it's just because they won't premiere -
later next year they didn't say when but
they'll also probably only be doing half
seasons like 10 to 13 episodes maybe
less for their next seasons - and
because they're not starting till later
next year that's also part of the reason
why those shows won't be featured a lot
during the next big crossover we'll see
how that changes in future seasons when
they get back to their normal production
schedule pretty much everybody in
Hollywood and everyone around the world
are slowly starting to film stuff again
later this year but it'll be next year
before there's a vaccine for the virus
and life won't completely go back to
normal until everybody gets the vaccine
but surprisingly we know a lot about
what's happening with the next seasons
of all the DC TV shows so we have any
big questions about what's going out
with Superman all their big Justice
League stuff that they're trying to set
up in the air overs just let me know in
the comments because that's basically
where they're heading with this that's
the whole reason for the challenge of
the Super Friends teaser at the end of
crisis on Infinite Earths they have
their Hall of Justice now they're going
to start doing more
Justice League stuff eventually had the
virus not happened we probably would
have seen a much bigger Justice League
style crossover but I think they're
going to slowly work up to that again - in
future seasons
congratulations kelp baths are your the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everyone click here for my brand-new
Marvel x-men video and trailer breakdown
and click here for my flash season 7
teaser video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
see you guys tonight!